but joining us now with reaction to all
we've been talking about Fox News
correspondent at-large Geraldo Rivera
trial attorney Rebecca
Rose woodland and she's the host you
know while justice with judge Jeanine
judge Jeanine Pirro is with us let me
start with you you know I saw this
unfold
I see the Twitter report by Carrick I
know they got sucked in they had no idea
who this group was this is the biggest
Pro censorship group in the country and
I don't want the the workers for the
keurig fired I don't want them now
unbeknownst to be my people that love
this show love this channel see it they
said find you if you're gonna pick sides
they advertise on ms on CNN everywhere
yeah everybody loves coffee
no matter your political view judge
here's what we saw America gets it
America gets that what is happening now
is that the left is not only trying to
shut down the right on college campuses
with their safe spaces and all that
other nonsense but they are trying to
shut us down they are trying to prevent
people from watching us trying to get us
fired
and they are using people like a caring
and all those other like coffee
companies or coffeemaker companies from
you know making us in or allowing us to
be on television television because
people advertise on our show servitors
drink coffee liberals drink it you know
I got to give the CEO of cures and I was
inclined to just keep going with us yep
but I stopped when I saw his statement I
said you know what he was a victim here
I they don't understand the bot
programming they don't understand the
agenda you know but but the fact that
the left is so anti-free speech today
when all these attacks against
conservatives come up you know who never
speaks up liberals I thought they were
free speech you know they're not because
they would be supporting the right of
people to watch the show and advertisers
to freely watch this show they
silent what do you make of that well
what we make of it is that there was a
first amendment in this country and the
First Amendment is there for a reason
the founding fathers and the
Constitution clearly states that there
can be two sides let's let everyone have
a freedom of speech that's what
democracy is if we don't have freedom of
speech what does it become fascism
socialism the point of freedom of speech
is so that people can hear views people
can understand and make their own
evaluations nobody has to watch the show
but by the way never to now your support
saving this year liberals and
conservatives should watch your show why
not why don't we listen to different
opposing opinions and make our own
decisions and don't come to rash
conclusions the point of law is that we
are innocent until proven guilty
Sean you never said I was here Friday
you never said you supported Roy Moore
you never said that should I support I
support not rushing to judgment that's
very different than support I support
the presumption of innocence and let me
bring her although in her although you
actually well by the way if I'm not here
her although our fun debates go away
forever and I would hate to have that
happen we disagree but we get along
great you one of the things that I love
about you speak your mind when the left
literally praised that interview I
thought I did the right thing this is a
serious allegation should be
non-political we should get to the truth
everybody deserves the presumption of
innocence I'm not backing down from one
thing I said in here I think that's the
right position and I don't like rush to
judgment boycotts stink with hypocrisy
stinks even worse than boycotts when you
have a group like media matters which
professes to support and protect the
First Amendment undermining the First
Amendment rights of everyone else to
have access to the shows that they want
to watch that is such gross hypocrisy is
grotesque
the other thing is everyone admits that
no one put the nail in Roy Moore's
political coffin more effectively than
you I knew that
I know that was not your intention but
when you asked the tough questions you
asked every single question that had to
be asked and his answers didn't match
the ferocity of the accusations everyone
even those on the fence suddenly we're
saying to Roy Moore hey judge maybe you
better fought by the way Ted Cruz pulled
his support for judge Moore that yeah
that's yeah
that is HUGE HUGE news tonight well is
that 5th accuser and then that whole
inscription in the yearbook my goodness
how creepy is it that a district
attorney signs a 17 year old kids
yearbook and signs it with flourishes
and love I'm surprised it in put a heart
a broken heart why don't you call me in
xxx I mean it was pretty its
contemporaneous proof as I've asked for
in these cases because you know you have
no statute of limitations this case is
38 years old well 40 years old in the
case of the fifth accuser today you have
no but you have some contemporaneous
corroboration that Roy Moore the
district attorney was hitting on this
high school senior what look I spent my
career doing this and trying to assess
between a complaint and whether or not
there is sufficient evidence to go
forward with a criminal case prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that a crime
has been committed and make no mistake
everybody talks about the presumption of
innocence but every time a prosecutor
goes into that grand jury we don't go
into the grand jury thinking we're going
to give them the presumption of
innocence we go in saying we're going to
get a conviction here now this fifth
person and the statement that you gave
it is compelling evidence and there is
no question based upon what I read in
that statement that this 32 year old
district attorney was grooming this
young girl going to her place of
business where as a young waitress she
would stay there until 10 o'clock at
night he was there in the same seat
every night waiting until she left he
complimented her he touched her hair he
waited until she left and would leave
when she left he then talked about
whether or not she would need a ride
home he took her home he was targeting
her sizing her up
contemporaneous confirming corroborating
evidence in the yearbook joy more it's
all there
this only came out today right we have
seen those kids with Duke Lacrosse
wrongly falsely accused and eighty-eight
professors jumped on the bandwagon rush
to judge British kids lives will forever
be impacted that was a case so is it
wrong you you were convinced today
weren't you it was today that was that
year Vince it was just the yearbook look
women young girls do not feel that in a
situation where someone has power but
today was a tipping point for you today
was a tip who has more power than a
sitting da that man don't rush the
judgment in light of Clarence Thomas and
light a Duke Lacrosse and by the first
urges in Trayvon all these people are
wrong so often we cannot wanted a
Russell tonight tipped your bells
today tipped it I know you should be
clear you didn't rush to judgment but
you put an interview on national
television for many it's not as if you
didn't cover the story you covered it
clearly you were so effective you were
better than any attorney I know in a in
a cross-examination why am I in this
business
notes to you you tip this game to people
because judge it's too serious this
isn't a game these are people's lives
you cannot I am a father of a daughter
right I am a brother to sisters
Geraldo let you weigh in I think that
when you mention the fact that you have
a teenage girl and you found the whole
concept of someone in his early 30s
particularly person with authority and
power like a district attorney dating
someone your daughter's age you would
find that disgusting outrageous you
would not tolerate it for a second and I
think that in that moment Sean you
became the surrogate for dads everywhere
all across the country and I think with
that question and his halting and
contradictory answer you really took
this from a remote charge and if it's
true kind of context to one that really
allowed people to put themselves in that
position and suggest you know something
this is really creepy this guy is really
beyond the pale and it's just you know
it gives you the kind of heebie-jeebies
and is this the person now I understand
Alabama and you know my lawyers from
Birmingham I was honored down there I
really I love Alabama but it has a
quirky defiant straight to it and I
think that we have to appeal to the
Alabama voters now the common sense and
I believe that they will rise to the
occasion then even though they wanted to
fly the man this is the case where
they've got to go with the elderly have
seconds okay but it's not about that
right now
what it's about now is about the fact
that people will see this for what it is
this isn't about politics anymore this
is about people seeing as someone who
was grooming a young woman and a sexual
predator look Friday I I had already
determined that I didn't believe
interesting I I did not believe him I
told Sean that but that doesn't mean we
don't cover it further that doesn't mean
we don't rush to judgment yeah but now
today with this accuser I am even more
certain I have been right than wrong in
most of my career because I don't rush
to judgment these are people's lives
there's a reason
one of the big 10 commandments is thou
shalt not bear false witness when that
happens it's bad but if somebody's a
predator we gotta get the truth
we don't need these people on the street
you spent a lifetime putting those
people away all right thank you all for
being with us